i'm right here i'm right here
the kardashians only know one way to
celebrate the holidays
big big big it is my holiday must-have
on sunday easter was a family affair for
the kardashians and jenners
good job hiding the eggs guys there's
lots of food
hope you're hungry the family headed to
kris jenner's palm springs
away home how cute is my mom
seriously i'm a big
presentation person where the kids had a
blast on an easter egg hunt
this room there's some in the trees
while everyone was in their sunday's
best kylie had
on an on brand color palette for easter
showing off this purple look
all over her instagram wanna do a twirl
can i see your dress
not to be outdone chloe shared this
adorable moment with kim's daughter
chicago
can i see your dress wow ladies
courtney's new man travis barker was
there for the festivities
he posted these photos to his instagram
which showed off while momager kris
jenner is the reigning queen
of holiday gifts i was in charge of
easter baskets
because that's my thing on top of these
beautifully crafted easter egg baskets
for the grandkids
kris jenner gifted each of her kids a
set of golf clubs
look what she got all of us oh my god
you guys
and no need to wonder who's whose she
got their names monogrammed on the bags
oh my gosh i just woke up on this easter
sunday
and came into the kitchen and my mom
treats easter like it's christmas you
guys have no idea
and this easter appears to be business
as usual for the family
kim kardashian showed et just how
serious their mom commits to the spring
holiday yeah my family and i we get
together every easter and we go to
church in the morning and then we have a
big brunch afterwards and then we have
an easter egg hunt
so we have to spend the entire day with
our family whether we like it or not
so today we are at sunday service
it is so huge i mean 50 000 people are
here
it's insane i just hope that everything
is just perfect
kim and chloe also gave some love to dmx
and their instagram
stories the rapper was rushed to the
hospital on friday night
following a reported drug overdose
[Music]
the sisters shared these videos from
2019
when dmx led kanye west's sunday service
on easter
so i pray that you allow our spirits to
be born
grow strong move on no right from wrong
[Music]
you